THE FACT THAT HE WAS REJECTED BY
AN ARIZONA COURT AND EXPRESSING
FRUSTRATION ABOUT THAT, AND
MEADOWS RESPONDS, PATHETIC.
THE ISSUE WITH THIS IS THAT THIS
BECAME A MORE CLANDESTINE EFFORT
AFTER THESE FIRST INITIAL
EFFORTS WERE REJECTED BY THE
COURT.
>> STRONG LANGUAGE.
EVAN PEREZ, STAY RIGHT HERE.
WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
SECOND.
>>> FIRST I WANT TO BRING IN
CNN'S DON LEMON, JOINING US WITH
NEW INFORMATION ON THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INSURRECTION.
DON, I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU JUST
SPOKE WITH DOCUMENTARY
FILMMAKERS WHO SPENT TIME WITH
ROGER STONE.
THEY'VE BEEN COOPERATING AND
TURNING OVER SOME OF THE FOOTAGE
TO THE COMMITTEE.
WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU?
>> WE SPOKE WITH THEM JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO, IT IS CALLED "A
STORM FORETOLD".
ONE OF THEM, ALEX, IS
CHRISTOPHER BRANSON, THE
DIRECTOR AND PRODUCER, AND
THERE'S A DIRECTOR OF
PHOTOGRAPHY.
THEY HAD UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS
WITH ROGER STONE AND THEY WERE
MAKING THIS DOCUMENTARY ON HIM.
THEY WANTED TO SEE WHAT HIS
CONNECTIONS WERE, IF THERE WERE
ANY, BETWEEN THESE GROUPS LIKE
THE PROUD BOYS, ET CETERA.
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE ASKED
FOR THEIR FOOTAGE OF STONE
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th AND THE
2020 ELECTION, AND THEY HANDED
IT OVER.
THAT INCLUDES A CLIP LIKE THIS
OF ROGER STONE, THIS ONE IS FROM
NOVEMBER 2nd OF 2020, ON HIS WAY
HOME FROM A DOUG COLLINS RALLY
IN GEORGIA.
LET'S WATCH IT.
>> EXCELLENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ BLEEP ].
>> LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
>> SHOOT TO KILL.
ANTIFA, SHOOT TO KILL.
I'M DONE WITH THIS.
>> SO SHOOT TO KILL, DONE WITH
THIS BS.
THIS WAS THE DAY BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
THE FILMMAKERS TOLD ME THAT
STONE ALSO RENOUNCED VIOLENCE
DURING THE TIME THEY SPENT WITH
HIM BUT THEY DIDN'T FIND IT
SINCERE.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS MORE OF A
WINK AND A NOD.
AND YOU HEARD WHAT HE SAID IN
THAT CLIP.
>> YEAH, SHOOT TO KILL.
JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
DON, YOU HAVE ANOTHER CLIP THAT
HAS ROGER STONE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR PLAN TO JUST CLAIM VICTORY
IN THE ELECTION EVEN IF THEY
LOST.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ALEX.
THIS OTHER CLIP SHOWS ROGER
STONE IMPLORING THE PEOPLE IN
HIS ORBIT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
CLAIM TRUMP'S VICTORY, NO MATTER
WHAT, ON ELECTION NIGHT.
HERE IT IS.
>> LET'S JUST HOPE WE'RE
CELEBRATING.
I SUSPECT IT WILL BE -- I REALLY
DO SUSPECT IT WILL BE STILL UP
IN THE AIR.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THE KEY THING
TO DO IS TO CLAIM VICTORY.
POSSESSION IS NINE-TENTHS OF THE
LAW, NO, WE WON, SORRY, YOU'RE
WRONG.
[ BLEEP ].
>> THAT WAS BEFORE A WINNER WAS
DECIDED IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
AND THE FILMMAKERS TOLD ME THAT
IT IS CLEAR TO THEM THAT THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS MOST
INTERESTED IN LINKS BETWEEN
STONE AND GROUPS LIKE THE PROUD
BOYS AND THE OATH KEEPERS AS
WELL.
I NEED TO SHARE WITH YOU A
STATEMENT FROM ROGER STONE ABOUT
THESE CLIPS.
HE DID RESPOND AND SAYS I
CHALLENGE THE ACCURACY AND
AUTHENTICITY OF THESE VIDEOS AND
BELIEVE THEY HAVE BEEN
MANIPULATED AND SELECTIVELY
EDITED.
I ALSO POINT OUT THAT FILMMAKERS
DO NOT HAVE THE LEGAL RIGHT TO
USE THEM, HOW IRONIC THAT KIM
KARDASHIAN AND I ARE BOTH
SUBJECTED TO COMPUTER
MANIPULATED VIDEOS ON THE SAME
DAY.
THE EXCERPTS YOU PROVIDED BELOW
PROVE NOTHING.
CERTAINLY THEY DO NOT PROVE I
HAD ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
EVENTS OF JANUARY 6th.
THAT BEING SAID, IT CLEARLY
SHOWS I ADVOCATED FOR LAWFUL
CONGRESSIONAL AND JUDICIAL
OPTIONS.
THAT IS WHAT ROGER STONE SAYS.
AND YOU CAN WATCH, OBVIOUSLY,
THE REST OF IT TONIGHT ON MY
SHOW FOR MORE CLIPS FROM THE
FILMMAKERS.
WATCH THEIR INTERVIEW AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR MORE ABOUT WHAT
THEY HAVE TO SAY ABOUT ROGER
STONE AND THEIR OWN INTERACTIONS
WITH THE 1/6 COMMITTEE.
>> COMPUTER ALTERED CLIPS.
QUITE A STATEMENT.
>> I HAD NO IDEA THAT KIM
KARDASHIAN WAS SUBJECTED TO --
YES OR NO WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
I'LL HAVE TO CHECK.
>> I MISSED THAT HEADLINE.
I'LL HAVE TO CHECK AFTER THE
SHOW AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SIR.
DON IS GOING TO HAVE SO MUCH
MORE ON ROGER STONE AND THOSE
CLIPS TONIGHT ON "DON LEMON
TONIGHT" AT 10:00 P.M. EASTERN
ON CNN.
>>> LET'S GET REACTION AND
ANALYSIS FROM A DEFENSE ATTORNEY
AND CNN COUNTERTERRORISM ANALYST
AND OUR CNN JUSTICE
CORRESPONDENT EVAN PEREZ IS BACK
WITH US AS WELL.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH ME.
PHIL, I WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST.
YOUR REACTION JUST TO THOSE
CLIPS, THAT INTERVIEW, AND WHAT
QUESTIONS DOES IT RAISE FOR YOU
ABOUT ROGER STONE AND WHO HE WAS
WITH AROUND JANUARY 6th.
>> BOY, I THINK MY REACTION IS
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION AND
A COURT OF LAW.
THE QUESTIONS I WOULD HAVE AS AN
ANALYST LOOKING AT THIS CASE ARE
BASED IN FACT.
WE KNOW WHAT ROGER STONE
THOUGHT, SO LET'S GO TO WHAT HE
DID.
ON THE DAY BEFORE, THE DAY OF,
THE DAY AFTER JANUARY 6th, I
WANT TO SEE PHONE RECORDS THAT
INDICATE WHETHER HE SPOKE WITH
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE BUILDING,
I WANT THE INTERVIEWS OF PEOPLE
IN THE BUILDING INDICATING WHAT
ROGER STONE TOLD THEM,
PARTICULARLY WHETHER HE KNEW,
WHETHER HE HAD FOREKNOWLEDGE OF
VIOLENCE AND WHETHER HE
ENCOURAGED VIOLENCE WHILE IT
HAPPENED.
YOU LISTEN IN THAT CLIP TO WHAT
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT AND HE
MENTIONS THE WORD "PROOF".
HE CLEARLY KNOWS HE'S IN
TROUBLE.
BUT WHERE HE KNOWS HE'LL GET OFF
THE HOOK IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SAYING, YEAH, I TOLD
PEOPLE VIOLENCE IS OKAY AND,
YEAH, THERE'S EVIDENCE, AND I
MEAN FACT, THAT INDICATES THAT I
TOLD PEOPLE TO GO IN AND COMMIT
AN ACT OF VIOLENCE ON JANUARY.
THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION IS
GOING TO SAY HE'S GUILTY.
IN A COURT OF LAW I THINK HE'S
STILL GOT SOME WIGGLE ROOM.
>> SHAN, TO YOU, THE FULL
PICTURE OF HOW ALL OF THESE
GROUPS COORDINATED, THAT'S STILL
UNCLEAR.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS PHONE CALL
BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE, SOMEONE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AND THAT
RIOTER, NINE SECONDS, WE'VE
HEARD MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DOWNPLAYING THE SIGNIFICANCE.
DO YOU SEE ANY EXPLANATION FOR
THE CALL?
>> THERE COULD BE A LOT OF
EXPLANATIONS FOR THE CALL.
IT'S CERTAINLY IMPORTANT TO
PURSUE IT, AND I SUSPECT THE
REASON THE COMMITTEE IS
DOWNPLAYING IT MORE HAS TO DO
WITH THEIR BEING UNHAPPY WITH
ANY PIECES LEAKING OUT.
LIKE MOST CRIMINAL CASES, WE'VE
GOT THE CRIME ON JANUARY 6th
THAT OCCURRED AND NOW THEY'RE
TRYING TO MOVE BACKWARDS AND
STATEMENTS LIKE STONE'S, THIS
PHONE CALL, ARE ALL INDICATIVE
OF SOMEONE, SEVERAL PEOPLE
THINKING OF THE CRIME
BEFOREHAND.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM IN
BETWEEN THAT'S GOT TO BE FILLED
UP.
SO THAT'S THE REALLY TOUGH PART,
IS TO FILL IN ALL THOSE BLANKS
IN SUCH A MASSIVE, SPRAWLING
INVESTIGATION.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK.
>> EVAN, WE ARE HOPING TO HAVE
SOME OF THOSE BLANKS FILLED IN
IN WHAT COULD BE THE LAST PUBLIC
INVESTIGATIVE HEARING BY THE
COMMITTEE ON WEDNESDAY.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
PRETTY VAGUE ABOUT WHAT TO
EXPECT.
DO WE HAVE ANY INDICATIONS ABOUT
THE THEME OR THEMES ON
WEDNESDAY?
>> WE EXPECT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
EXTREMISM THAT DROVE SOME OF THE
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th, AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE PIECES HERE THAT I
THINK THEY'VE BEEN BUILDING AND
TRYING TO DEVELOP FROM
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE THAT I THINK
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY PUT
OUT TO THE PUBLIC.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S AN INTERESTING
TIME -- COINCIDENCE IN TIMING,
OBVIOUSLY, OF THIS HEARING
BECAUSE SOME OF THE OATH
KEEPERS, SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE EXTREMIST GROUP THAT WERE
VIOLENT, CARRIED OUT THE
VIOLENCE ON JANUARY 6th, ARE
GOING ON TRIAL BEGINNING
TOMORROW HERE IN WASHINGTON,
D.C.
WE'LL SEE A SPLIT SCREEN MOMENT
THERE WHERE I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE SOME OF THE OATH KEEPERS,
SOME OF THE MEMBERS AND THEIR
LAWYERS THAT ARE GOING TO TRY TO
BRING THIS UP BEFORE A JUDGE TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
THIS AFFECTS THE FAIRNESS OF
THEIR TRIAL.
AND WE'LL SEE WHETHER THAT DOES
OR NOT.
>> PHIL, THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY
STRANDS IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE SAID THAT
IT'S HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT WE'LL
GET A REPORT BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, BEFORE THE BEGINNING
OF NOVEMBER.
HOW DOES THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE TIE UP THE LOSE ENDS
OF THIS SPRAWLING INVESTIGATION
FROM THOSE MEADOWS TEXTS, TO
WITNESS TAMPERING, THE SECRET
SERVICE TEXT MESSAGES?
THERE'S SO MUCH TO NOW TIE UP IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
>> WELL, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
ALEX, IN 30 SECONDS LET ME
SIMPLIFY THIS.
THERE'S TWO SEPARATE STORIES AND
THEY ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT.
THE FIRST STORY IS TO THE
AMERICAN POPULUS SAYING IF YOU
ELECT SOMEBODY WHO ENCOURAGES
PEOPLE TO COMMIT ACTS OF
VIOLENCE, YOU CAN UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY.
THAT IS NOT A LEGAL ARGUMENT,
THAT IS NOT AN ARGUMENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
BUT I THINK THE PRIMARY MESSAGE
FROM THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO BE TO VOTERS AND
CITIZENS LIKE ME, LIKE YOU, TO
SAY BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT YOU
WISH FOR BECAUSE YOU MAY GET IT.
LET ME DIFFERENTIATE THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TAKES
ACTION.
I DISAGREE WITH ANY EFFORTS BY
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE TO
REFER CASES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THE LAW ELEMENT OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SHOULD MAKE CASES
INDEPENDENT OF POLITICIANS.
THE QUESTION ABOUT LEG